les joueurs de l'équipe amour du disque
peuvent savourer les roses viennent de
remporter le 14e 0 peu de plaisir
l'un des plus grands tournois indoor
d'ultimate en ile de france
c'était un match très intense très fair
play et qu'ils gagnent à la fin de
justesse donc on est super contents
c'est un tournoi qu'on aime bien faire
ça fait plusieurs années qu'on peut
faire on était là lors de la première
édition
et puis bah on essaie de le faire chaque
année donc quand on a la chance d'être
pris c'est avec grand plaisir que on
honore notre sélection depuis 1997 le
rendez vous organisé par le club zéro
gènes de plaisir prend de l'ampleur
cette année le tournoi amical est passé
de huit à douze équipes venues de la
région francilienne
et pour la première fois la centaine de
joueurs présents s'est affrontés sur
deux gymnases au palais des sports et
sur nicholas leur certains joueurs font
leur première expérience aux airs open
c'est un tournoi qui se renouvelle avec
des nouveaux joueurs chaque année et
puis oui
l'ultimate en france grandi prend de
l'ampleur avec différents championnats
que ce soit en salle en extérieur ou sur
plage c'est une pratique assez un sport
en développement donc là on apprécie le
zéro pn reviendra l'année prochaine pour
une nouvelle édition le club zéro g
n'aura en 2019 deux objectifs faire
grandir encore un peu plus au rendez
vous et tentez de remporter le tournoi
pour la première fois de son histoire